morning everyone we start with breaking
news on inflation we've just had the
figures uh within the last few seconds
bad news back to double digits let's
find out more Paul is standing by for us
in The Newsroom um hi Paul what's the
latest
yeah good morning Kay uh CPI Consumer
Price inflation has risen again in
August it's back above 10 news today it
has risen to 10.1 percent from the
August number of 9.9 that takes it back
to where it was in July itself a figure
that was last higher in the early 1990s
so close to record highs for inflation
10.1 percent that means obviously bad
news for consumers the cost of living
squeeze is going to continue it tells us
it is continuing is likely to continue
the biggest driver of this increase in
inflation according to the office for
National statistics is food prices food
inflation that is a combination of both
the input costs the cost of importing
many of the raw materials and the basic
Commodities on which our food is based
as well as transport costs while fuel
prices are dropping back it is still
very expensive to move Goods around the
country and there is plenty of evidence
reflected in these figures that
supermarkets and other retailers are
passing on these costs now to Consumers
but the other place apart from every
household in the country where this will
be watched is of course in Whitehall we
have a new chance of the exchequer
attempting to balance the books and this
figure matters today the 10.1 percent
inflation figure for September matters
because it is the figure against which
pensions and benefits will be uprated if
big if the conservative party and the
government sticks to its Manifesto
pledge but that is now in play so 10.1
percent an extremely high inflation
figure and an expression of the reality
of the cost of living squeeze for
everyone in the UK